most of us have a general understanding
that games playing in relationships is a
bad thing
and that all good people are opposed to
them i don't play games is a favorite
mantra declaimed by hopeful people at
the beginning of love stories the world
over
however it can be less obvious what
games playing really involves
and therefore how definitively to avoid
its dynamics
we too often associate this so-called
sport with its most obvious
manifestations in the dating phase
for example when a person hides their
desire beneath a veneer of indifference
or goes cold as soon as love is
reciprocated
but there are plenty of other forms of
games playing that are far more
insidious invisible and in the long run
dangerous
they occur whenever we decide to stop
saying something difficult
vulnerable or hurt that is on our minds
and camouflage an injury instead
we play games when our partner does or
says something that wounds us
but we choose not to reveal it
we stay silent and smiley
because to be honest would make us feel
exposed desperate cloying and weak
in front of someone who we fear might
simply not care enough about us to
listen
therefore we opt to initiate a so-called
game in which we do the following
we bury our ruffled feelings about this
or that problem
but we do so very badly
in the deliberate hope that our partner
will in time realize their offense and
then feel sorry for it and apologize
without us having to be naked about our
upset
the game sets out to provoke guilt as an
alternative to emotional frankness
so rather than tell a partner cleanly
that we're a bit upset that they didn't
for instance buy us the medicine we ask
them to pick up on their way back from
work
we play the game of blithely not caring
about their forgetting
we stay silent and then the next morning
we go to the chemist ourselves and leave
the box in the receipt prominently on
the kitchen table
when as we had hoped they spot it and
immediately say oh god i'm so sorry
we smile casually and reply oh don't
worry that's fine it wasn't to bother
for me
it may seem like a tiny incident but the
seismologists of relationships will know
that this is likely to be the harbinger
of something far bigger
a fateful pattern of not declaring what
is wrong
of hoping to be read without explaining
of not daring to speak about what
matters
all of which can over time
lead to a grave erosion of trust and
destructive indirect methods of
communication
that bring anger and resentment in their
wake
games playing is a subset of behavior we
know as sulking
when we sulk it's because a partner has
in some way offended us
they've told a story in public that we
wanted to be kept private
they've shown us a lack of tact they've
forgotten an important occasion they
have failed to listen to us
but the sulka acts as if from an
unhelpfully romantic hope
that they should be interpreted without
needing to speak
they dream that someone who truly loved
them would guess what they were upset
about without requiring the offence to
be spelt out to them in a medium as
clumsy and as slow as language
they want to be understood without words
anyone who fails to do this is quickly
taken by the sulka to be badly
intentioned
there is little space to believe in
innocent failures of empathy
the partner hasn't merely failed to
grasp what is going on
their failure is willed
they are doing this on purpose
to a feeling of abandonment the sulka
adds a layer of persecution
for the sulka it is a great deal more
tempting to devote the next six hours to
answering curtly
insisting that nothing is wrong
and affecting a pained and melancholy
look than to strive to delineate the
nature of their hurt
we are taking our first steps towards a
less fraught kind of coupledom
when we are finally able to tell someone
who has upset us
that they have upset us
preferably within the very half hour in
which they have done so
a true commitment to not playing games
involves a profound effort directly to
say everything that has upset us at once
it could sound like we are being
difficult however so long as we are
polite
communicating hurt is anything but poor
behavior
it's the greatest privilege to be in
love with a true adult
who can tell us what is wrong precisely
when a problem occurs
and is brave enough to present
themselves as weak
so that love can stay strong
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more
you